هل فكرتم يوما كيف تتالم النباتات وهل
تتالم بصمت كما هو حالها دائما حسنا هناك
دراسه علميه جديده رصدت اصواتا لانين
النبات بالطبع ليس بالطريقه نفسها التي
يصرخ بها البشر ولكنها تصدر ضوضاء في
ترددات فوق صوتيه خارجا نطاق السمع البشري
وفقا للدراسه فان هذه الاصوات واحده من
الطرق التي تنقل بها النباتات والمها
[موسيقى]
ما سمعتموه الان انين لنباتات الطماطم
تعرضت لانواع مختلفه من الاجهاد كالجفاف
او البروده العلماء رصدوا هذه الاصوات
بواسطه مكبرات خاصه وتوصلوا ايضا الى ان
النباتات المحيطه تفهم وتستجيب لتلك
الموجات فمثلا عند سماعها اصواتا صادره من
نباتات تعرضت للجفاف فانها تغلق مساماتها
بشكل تلقائي لمنع فقدان الماء